so nice to meet you tiffany you look
gorgeous today oh my goodness i love
your hair
thank you
this this is called i slept last night
and here i put a little hairspray in it
and that's it
so anything is gorgeous after that place
for real though so obviously how are you
feeling today after watching it all play
back last night oh i feel like my my
bank account is is not as heavy as i'd
like it to be ugh
listen um i feel fine like i'm really
okay i got experience of a lifetime like
it sucks not to win and i really think i
could have um there were a lot of twists
there was a lot of luck there was a lot
of
bad loyalty going on um last night was a
hot mess
um
and you know wasn't it wasn't my time so
maybe i'll get him next time but yeah it
was uh it was it was weird to watch back
because um
i did see like you know heather jumping
up and trying to save me
and ending up almost voting herself out
ultimately and it became between me and
heather instead of between xander and me
nothing gets flashed heather votes me
lyanna votes me when you're after xander
for like freaking 16 days like what is
why like why
so like
you know it was just really a weird vote
out
and um
not that i was blindsided because i i
thought it was going to be split but
maybe between like xander or insear and
me so like we're flushing things and
then ultimately xander being like oh
they're not going to really write my
name down and then he goes home with his
stuff in his pocket right and if he
wasn't going to use it use it on me zero
loyalty not a fan thought it was bad bad
bad play like really it was like
why i showed you so much loyalty last
week like
that move that we made was evie and i
came to him with that with that whole
move it made it look like it was him he
actually almost blew it up by telling
danny by you know being performative at
the thing and lyanna's just i don't know
how she didn't like read the room dude
like how do you not know he has it like
that one of us has it you know but it is
what it is that's why it's a game
because people don't think the same way
and
strategy went out the window old
survivor like get the people out with
the idols and with things like that out
the window
who knew
who knew
so how did you really feel about xander
pulling out that fake idol last week
because people on twitter were like oh
such a good move but what being there
obviously is a different moment
so you know here's the thing
maybe that was his moment to be like oh
this is my moment but evie and i came up
with that plan
so he got the credit we came up with the
plan i was the one who found out about
the idol she was shannon was um lyanna
was ultimately supposed to give it up to
shan so that ooh i would come work with
us she she didn't do it she was supposed
to do that instead she kept it for
herself forgot to tell shan that she
wasn't going to tell us which is why
shannon brought it up in front of us and
then proceeds to tell shannon how close
she is with us so why would shannon
bring it up right then gets mad at me
because she lied to me like what
and now puts his name puts my name down
over xander's at final tribal for me
like what
none of it made any sense it was so
emotional and
um xander doing that move i thought was
terrible actually to be fair like
why would you say something to danny you
almost blew up that whole thing because
danny was like let's use it on a sear
instead if it wasn't for lyanna being so
hot on getting xander out
that whole plan would have blown up in
our faces
right like
it would have been like somebody now now
they have more power they have the
serious idol because dan you couldn't
keep your mouth shut like why would you
tell him and then pulling showing the
fake idol like
to me read the room dude how do you not
know that he how do you not know he
doesn't have it like that would never
have worked on me never
all in the name of survivor right
i was sad
how do you feel to be the first member
of jury though that's an accomplishment
especially in this season
oh you know queen of ponderosa
i'm still a queen
how do i feel i feel super proud of
myself you know like people
my edit in the beginning made me look
not smart not strategic i was quite
smart and quite strategic i'm from new
york we are gritty we know what's going
on 99 of the time like stop it y'all and
then they're all like i hate tiffany
groups and all of a sudden now the whole
world loves me i don't even know how
that happened
but like
i was like you know
i just i'm so grateful that i was out
there and that was such a win
but i really feel like i could have won
that if this was old survivor where
social game play and reading a room was
important
i might have had that because honestly i
i have no pro like
the people there if i was such a threat
because of social but at the same time
having an idol and having all that power
in your pocket didn't make you a threat
this season it made you like safe like
what like made no sense you know so like
i that's not a game i'm used to i feel
like a lot of it came down to luck
um
not a fan of that but okay it happens
it's the news it's the new you know
season
drop the four
keep the one with the idol in the game i
don't get it right so like
yeah you know it's i can't say enough
about having done it and meeting the
people that i've met evie is a lifelong
i mean she's
just fabulous sydney and i left our
butts off out there um me and myself and
voucher super super close i mean some
lovely brilliant wonderful people um and
we had a great little tribe going you
know it just fell apart and it that's
not survivor people know you stick
together but nobody ever does it
it seems like the people with the idols
are almost playing it safe this season
like they're not making big moves what
would you have done if you had an idol
so if i would have well if i had it last
night or if i had it in general
just in general oh i would have
mastermind some crazy [ __ ] where i would
have had lyanna like tell her that i was
giving it to somebody but i was gonna
fake it out and not give it to her and
then use it on someone else to keep them
safe to pull them to my side i had [ __ ]
going on in my head that is diabolical
but you couldn't do it
you couldn't do it you couldn't get your
footing
so
the type of strategy even that evie and
i would come up with was mind-boggling
awesome
nowhere to make the moves
nowhere so if i had an idol i'd have
probably either used it on someone that
if i was in them not a good alliance or
i thought i sort of had somebody on the
fence and then they were going to be
voted out i probably have even played it
on them i thought xander should have
played his eyes on me last night that
would have been brilliant that's a move
yes
we would have had the numbers after that
we would have switched up this game
that's a boss move don't sit out for
grilled cheese you're a paleo you don't
eat grilled cheese
please
it's all the people sitting out for rice
with your idols in your pockets thank
you too like
this yutz has to go up there and play
because i have nothing in my pocket like
i could live without the rice another 16
days and you know what i got really thin
on that island and not for nothing but i
needed to be out there for another two
days just to look like a little cute out
there like give me another freaking day
i was on the survivor diet i was gonna
be like listen guys i don't care about
the million but i'd like to lose another
10 pounds so if you leave me out there a
little longer be great
but
they don't care they didn't care about
me so is that why you didn't step
forward for the rice you were just like
i don't want that rice anyways no i i
didn't feel safe enough first of all to
step oh oh is that no no i was like no
that rice is fattening carbs it's not
hot
not for me i'm going to starve another
16 days
i don't need it
please
i wasn't even hungry after a while it
was just like whatever
yeah you just get used to it that's
that's wild was there anything you were
really craving
um what i was craving is for everybody
to stop talking about what they want for
breakfast lunch and dinner every five
freaking seconds like what would you
have now i was like i would have i would
have i would eat anything that didn't
eat me first okay that's what i would
have right now can we stop talking about
food like please people please i'm
starving why are we talking about food
it's such a fun game it's not fun it's
not fun it's not fun i don't want to
talk about food i would but i was the
provider i got crabs by my hands they
bit me i was walking around them hanging
i was super provider in my tribe and i
also started the first fire they don't
show that they showed me on the freaking
bounds beam making sweet love to a
balanced beam
jerks
whatever i'm still a winner in our eyes
that is amazing
what are those moments like in tribal
where everyone gets up and starts
whispering what do you feel because that
just looks like chaos it it
looks feels and is chaos
it is the most listen i'm the first one
to jump up if i have a plan going and
you're all going to sit there and it's
my ass on the line but like it's very
um unsettling because you go in with an
idea of what you're going to do and you
just people are so emotional and
starving and not thinking and not firing
in all four cylinders that
a little bit of upsettedness which jeff
loves
really rocks the cart and then it's like
everything just starts falling off it's
like when you pull the wrong apple and
all of a sudden they'll fall out and all
scents and logic goes out the freaking
window and you got a bunch of starving
lunatics running around on a stage and
there's me
here we go again
somehow it's this person but it's gonna
be me like
just it's it's madness do i love it
listen i love it because if it's gonna
keep me safe great but as a viewer it's
like oh come on guys it actually got me
voted out last night it actually got me
voted out last night
so
whatever
who do you think is running everything
right now
you know i think the optics are making
it look like shan is running it i think
she's a great player don't get me wrong
and i think she's had a lot of time to
play because who i was you know got to
answer two people and i think that's
just by natural by nature you're gonna
see the natural progression of her game
because they had they had to vote people
off right and i think she was the
stronger of that of them out there and
um uh i forgot what i was saying what
were we doing now
i'm 48. wait what are we saying how do
you think you're running yeah
it seems like you can but when you got
on that stage right and it is chan to
some degree don't get me wrong but when
you got on that stage last night and you
saw
that
everybody wanted to switch it to heather
and deshawn jumps in and says i'm not
with it
and sham
placates him
i don't know
who's really running that show and if
you're on the island you're seeing that
there's a power struggle so to be honest
with you i think it is there is a
struggle within the struggle of who's
going to
within their tight alliances there's
power struggle going on and that's never
good um so i think last night's vote
ultimately was desean
that's interesting i never really
thought of that but
you have been on the island you've seen
the game play based on game play alone
who do you think should win
going forward yeah
oh on gameplay alone i would think
listen like
i don't know i would think the person's
name is never being written down and
it's just flying under the radar
you're doing something right
that's what i think is a fan like
watching it now i'm like
all right like for some reason i feel
like i'm the entire show like i'm like
why am i on there and i said to evie on
the phone i was like why the hell would
you let me go play in that bra how many
when am i getting dressed when am i
getting i remember saying to her like
how does this look she's like you look
great
i was like so i called her i'm like
eddie are you kidding me like
when am i getting dressed can you just
tell me when i wear a shirt because this
is just a nightmare like when do i
actually put a shirt on and what made me
think that that looked good like you're
real i must have really been starving
because that would never happen in real
life
parading around there like i'm l
mcpherson out there i can't i can't i
can't even a bo derek coming out of the
water and i'm like everything i'm like
okay this is great guys thanks thanks
thanks everybody
i spoke with sydney last week and she
said that she would have wanted you to
win because she loved you and she also
spoke about how she loved watching
herself and she loved seeing her cute
little split ends and things like that
is there any moment that you are going
to cherish that you saw on the show
um
[Music]
oh god i'm so fabulous i don't even know
what i'm just kidding
i'm just kidding um i really
loved listen
there is so much to take away from this
i had such a laugh with sydney on that
show that
i can't even tell you i mean we we peed
our pants evie and i were just laughing
24 7. it never ended um i mean ricardo
and i had a laugh that we'll never i'll
never forget but
you know last night's confessional i i
don't make myself laugh that much
because i'm busy making everybody else
that but i don't even remember saying
like crew crap that i thought that was
really funny
i was like timmy that was funny like
high five like you know
you know i i really i thought that was
great i mean
i kind of myself out there i just i am
who i am i am not different i'm a lot
funnier and more fun and energetic than
i think they showed but i think fans
kind of did get a sense of who i am
um in real life
and
i love that i love that that happens you
know i i thank cbs for like portraying
me kind of as stupid as they made me
look and as
absolutely terrible that the huntsman
thing was like that will live in me
forever by the way i single-handedly
think i ruined my son's college life he
was like mom what the f was that i'm
like i don't know honey i don't know
what it was
like go out go get some vodka i know
that was terrible you need to drink
tonight sweetheart
yeah so i think like you know my actual
energy people all my crazy things that i
did you see some of them on the extra on
the extra pieces if you get to go watch
them i had a lot
you were very entertaining for real
um so my last question for you is if you
could give any advice to people who are
looking to join survivor what would you
tell them
just um i i would not go into thinking
the game is going to be any which way
you ever saw before i think each and
every time you go out and play it could
be one new thing that screws up your
whole idea of what survivor is and i
went out like that but it still got me
survivor gets everybody every single
person and also i think you know you've
got to be really really really mentally
strong for this you know afterwards is
tough for people like those those people
i hate tiffany groups like i don't give
a [ __ ] but most people do but like
that's tough for people like you got to
have a very thick skin if you're going
to go out there you got to own it you
got to be resilient you got to just go
out there and play your heart out and
don't don't be embarrassed of who you
are like i don't care what i look like
whatever it was embarrassing but who
cares you know whatever
funny
iconic some would say
i have become an iconic queen i'm
starting to work on my wave because i'm
a queen
some of that stuff is so funny i'm like
you guys like who am i i'm just a mom
from long island like originally from
queens new york like but it's so funny
that people think i'm you know this
great amazing
superstar like okay this is great we
love to see it we love to see it
you